Tom Cruz might have big plans with
Warner Brothers Discovery after signing
a massive film deal but it looks like
he's heading back into the danger zone
before he gets there good morning
aviators this is your captain speaking
according to Puck Paramount wants to
swing the Top Gun franchise around for
another pass with Cruz returning for a
third film along with his top gun
Maverick co-stars Glenn Powell and Miles
Teller it's a no-brainer move from the
studio given that top gun Maverick
earned 1.5 billion dollars at the box
office making it the most successful
film of Cruz's entire career and the
second biggest in the studio history a
Hollywood newsletter also reports that
Aaron Krueger who co-wrote top gun
Maverick is typing away at a new script
presumably while wearing Aviator Shades
and listening to Great Balls of Fire
Puck sources also reveal that Joseph
kazinski is down to return to the
director's chair after hming the 2022
hit Whispers of a third Top Gun film
appeared on the radar within days of the
release of Maverick Miles Teller even
admitted to having brief chats with the
iconic wingmen about a third film in an
interview with Entertainment Tonight in
July 2022 teller said I yeah I've been
I've been uh having some conversations
with about it but you know we'll see
since then Cruz has been busy riding
bikes off of cliffs and climbing out of
bip planes for his final Mission
Impossible movie and he might still have
some work to do there before he feels
the need for speed again due to the SAG
after strike Mission Impossible a
altered production and had its release
date pushed back from June 2024 to May
23rd 2025 what that might mean for
scheduling a third Top Gun film is
unclear but with both these movies and
whatever mystery projects Cru is lining
up with Warner Brothers Discovery all on
the Stars plate there's obviously a lot
of work in Cruz's immediate future that
said Cruz isn't the type of actor who's
ever Shi away from a challenge as
evidenced by his history of Performing
crazy stunts that in mind who's up for
some beach volleyball better yet who
wants to see Cruz fly even higher into
the skies and possibly beyond the
actor's lucrative deal with Warner
Brothers Discovery to produce and star
in franchise friendly films will
undoubtedly further cement his status as
a box office Behemoth speculation is
already Rife about the wbd partnership
leading to a sequel to Edge of Tomorrow
the 2014 sci-fi headit about time Loops
in alien invasions that made over $370
million at the global box office the
sequel has been discussed for years and
now seems more possible than ever in
20121 director Doug Lyman told collider
that production hinged on Cruz and his
co-star Emily Blunt it's one of these
things where if Tom Emily and I were to
say we're ready to pull the trigger on
the script it's Tom Cruz and Emily Blunt
the film gets made however details about
which projects will materialize from
this partnership are being kept close to
the vest for now what we do know however
is that Cruz will be the first American
actor to go to space assuming all goes
according to plan the Daredevil actor is
currently working on a project that will
reunite him with Lyman and will see them
collaborate with Elon musk's SpaceX
program to shoot scenes beyond the stars
since he's known for performing death
defying stunts and pushing himself to
the limits being thrust into space
doesn't seem unusual for
[Music]
Crews